noi siamo
i sogni sono
cenerentola porca quando móvil a quel
commento o fai un bel suono sembri tipo
la risposta maschile di ariana grande
grande in realtà sto per dire la
risposta femminile ed oggi abbiamo un
ospite speciale una persona che ci
spiegherà come secondo alcuni studi
scientifici quello che può sembrare una
canzoncina per bambini fatta per stylist
per farli stare tranquilli in realtà è
molto di più
abbiamo ospite infatti una persona che
ha deciso di cambiare vita per
approfondire la propria conoscenza su
quello che il potere invisibile eppure
concreto dei nostri desideri oggi a
feroci avremo come ospite giuseppe
schiller il cognome non è un caso perché
stiamo parlando di una grandissima
persona che non è mai comparsa su questi
schermi di professione fa il fisico
nucleare e per 35 anni ha lavorato nel
settore della tecnologia e della
microelettronica lo leggo perché in
realtà non l'ho mai capito cosa facesse
è anche però perito stradale sommelier
ma soprattutto personal coach evolutivo
che santi cucinare il suo dolce
preferito il budino al cioccolato vive a
catania ha quattro figli uno sono io uno
dietro la camera e gli altri due saranno
saltando da un palazzo in fiamme ecco
perché sono contento e anche un po
spaventato nel presentarvi mio papà ma
facciamole entrare papa allora giuseppe
o se non volete chiamarlo anche poi papa
sa
come va abbastanza bene la prima volta
che parlo davanti a un microfono di
questo tipo la cosa difficile stare
attaccata al microfono fino ad oggi
nessuno ci è riuscito
c'erano
a roma ho capito ma la tua in sicurezza
di spinge offendermi ho detto aspetta
aspetta aspetta niente ragazza si inizia
da subito con litigio andiamo avanti
bravo lollo grazie per essere comunque
la persona più matura a questo tavolo
prego il mental coach come funziona
personal coach cosa che ti ha spinto a
cambiare così è da te e interessarti nei
primi tempi della mia vita diciamo più
per i primi 40 anni ero molto legato a
un mondo materialistico tutto ciò che è
materiale a tutto ciò che è diretto a
tutto ciò che è visibile cioè tutto
quello che le persone che l'essere umano
controlla e capisce tramite 56 e chiaro
che l'essere umano è estremamente
limitato in questo la vista è limitata
no entro un certo range di lunghezze
d'onda che sono quelle della luce
pensate un po le nostre orecchie che il
range così
ristretto anno nel campo dei suoni già
un cane riesce a percepire infrasuoni e
ultrasuoni il problema è proprio questo
viviamo in un mondo suicidario significa
che tutto quello che la società impone è
dettato da un pensiero capitalistico
tutto gira ok intorno ai soldi la nostra
vita è una vita alienata perché perché
non si tiene conto di un fatto
importante che noi siamo mortali e qua
il problema è che ci dice che noi siamo
mortali e lo sappiamo anche quando noi
non ci pensiamo il problema così che
invece la nostra vita è uno scappare
sempre da questa situazione e come
l'aereo sta precipitando tu c'hai il
bicchiere di coca cola dell'oste se sei
preoccupato dove mette il bicchiere gogò
la e il ragazzo l'aereo sta precipitando
e questo l'ha mai ha l'illusione che ci
danno cioè noi siamo concentrati sul
bicchiere di coca cola ma lei lo stack è
precipitato nei primi 40 anni io ero in
questa maglia in questa illusione che
fortissima poi dopo un fatto
spiacevole ho cambiato le mie priorità
ho iniziato a far sì che queste cinque
sensi invece di essere proiettati verso
l'esterno proiettiamo lì verso l'interno
questo è il primo passo da fare che è
arrivato diciamo un certo punto non
certo ben 40 anni a 40 anni quanti che
quanti anni devo fare cinque anni a
settembre sto per andare in pensione
speriamo e poi una volta andato in
pensione però come fisico hai deciso di
continuare col coaching è un'attività
che non faccio per i soldi ma faccio per
aiutare le persone perché io per 26 anni
ho iniziato a fare un certo tipo di
cammino che un cammino spirituale o una
domanda tt blocco al volo nel senso io
essendo quella persona che se non vede
non crede ok nel momento in cui mi si
parla invece di spiritualità di anima e
compagnia bella jean poi ne abbiamo
parlato improvvisamente mi sembra che si
parli di fuffa totale che non è
minimamente legata anche solo a un filo
di concretezza di spiegabili tap è
esattamente questo è proprio il problema
dell'alienazione che abbiamo in questa
società heidegger dice che noi siamo
buttati nella vita nelle mani della
nostra morte aveva però motivo si celi
un filo storico è così come sarà questa
che quando l'essere umano inizia a
prendere consapevolezza quando sei
bambino tu non hai questa consapevolezza
fino ai tre anni magari fine 6 anni poi
iniziò a prendere consapevolezza ed
aggredisce proprio questo in questi sei
anni tu sei programmato hai un
imprinting
come quello di twilight saga
l'imprinting è quella connessione no
l'imprinting facciamo un esempio
banalissimo l'esempio dei pulcini il
pulcino riconosce la mamma qualunque
cosa tu gli metti davanti basta che si
muova e allora se ha fatto questo tipo
di esperimento è stato preso uno spazio
un rettangolo e in questo rettangolo è
stato messo un piccolo oserei dire una
parola grossa al robottino che è un
piccolo sistema che praticamente tramite
un processo grande comico lui si sposta
del 50 per cento a testa al 50 per cento
sinistra in alto in basso dopo un certo
numero di tempo se tu hai a mappare gli
spostamenti di questo robottino vedi che
sono omogenei in tutta la superficie
benissimo sono stati messi 15 pulcini
che si sono schiusi è la prima cosa che
hanno visto è stato il robottino che si
muoveva quella mamma che qui niente di
strano strano che in questi quindici i
pulcini seguivano sul robottino sono
stati presi questi pulcini e messo in
una gabbia e sono stati messi a fianco
di questo spazio i pulcini volevano si
viene a mamma la loro intenzione era
questa ebbene il robottino non è stato
più omogeneo nei momenti dello spazio ma
si è mosso solo vicino la gabbietta ma
senza che nessuno l'avesse programmata
che no e noi che cosa programmi è stato
ripetutamente un'ottantina di volte con
i pulcini e funzionano sempre sempre
continuiamo i coniglietti i coniglietti
ovviamente si spaventano del robottino
sono piccolini che ha visto cosa che
spaventa è la stessa ma senza sabato ma
giovanili messi in una gabbia e
robottino si è portato dall altra parte
dello spazio perché i conigli avevano
paura i conigli sono stati affamati sul
robottino estromesso del cibo il
robottino col cibo si è avvicinato alla
gabbietta e ho iniziato a muoversi
vicino alla gabbietta finisco subito è
stato fatto con essere umano in fase di
sonno quindi fase inconscia questo
bottino e mettiamo un rumore fastidioso
ebbene senza l'essere umano che dorme il
robottino è sempre omogeneo nella sua ma
con l'essere umano inconscio il robot
sia allontanato il più possibile dalle
strumento per non darvi fastidio perché
c'è quindi una comunicazione c'è
un'azione spettrale che non è in realtà
quello che diciamo noi che gli alla
realtà ok ma la realtà che cos'è è solo
limitata a quello che noi vediamo che
cinque sensi già basta che tu metti un
radiotelescopio ti fa bene una realtà
completamente diverse tombe tra e mai ma
allora quando uno dice che le cose di
cui ha ri paura poi tele attiri se
questa questo spirito dice l'opposto
come questo esperimento non dice proprio
l'opposto va molto di moda questo col
fatto di parlare un po della legge
dell'attrazione eccezioni si chiama la
questione è che purtroppo non è che
pensando a cose belle che tu attiri cose
belle perché non è il tuo pensiero
cosciente e la tua intenzione cioè
l'aiuto stato di pre coscienza scusate
faccio una domanda proprio macro tutto
questo discorso afferisce sempre alla
fisica quantistica
voi sapete che
arrivato a un certo punto
nell'infinitamente piccolo
le leggi che noi vediamo nel
macroscopico non valgono più tipo un
esempio proprio per un esempio per una
persona ha fatto il classico di come un
esempio sciocco e quello
dell'internazionale di heisenberg
classico del collasso la funzione d'onda
e cioè in poche parole l'equazione di
schelling air è un'equazione che ha
delle soluzioni queste soluzioni se non
possiamo chiamate funzioni d'onda la
funzione d'onda il quadrato del modulo
della funzione d'onda ti dà la
probabilità di trovare una particella un
certo posto ok torniamo a parlare di
pulcini allora si capisce perché voglio
mai detto a che fare l'isola fisica
quantistica io ti dico sì nel senso che
non esiste la materia così come la
sentiamo noi ma la materia energia
l'energia e honda vibrazione noi siamo
fatti di vibrazione noi siamo vuoti se
uno ti dice ti dovesse fatto il tizio di
ci siamo fatti al 70 per cento di acqua
no noi siamo fatti di atomi e gli atomi
sono vuoti di miss è una cazzata se io
prendo un laccio una corda molto lunga
inizio a girarla velocissimo come se
avessi uno scudo ma è sanitario una
corda e noi siamo fatti di tante corde
che girano velocissime a sei piccoli
dobbiamo capire che tutta la materia
energia e che c'è questo legame la
famosa legge che tutti quanti conosco è
uguale emmeciquadro che mette
all'energia in relazione alla massa
tramite il quadrato della velocità della
luce d'accordo questa qua la conoscono
tutti ma nessuno ha mai credo
ricercatori questa
conosciamo solo per una foto famosissima
con la lingua di fuori
quindi c'è una relazione ben precisa tra
massa ed energia
la missione è questa e adesso facciamo
il passetto più lungo della gamba fin
quando noi non siamo coscienti delle
cose le cose sono energia sono onde
quando iniziamo essere coscienti oggi
iniziamo a fare delle misurazioni le
onde diventano materia un esempio
concreto per comprendere questa
affermazione vediamo un po se posso
spiegare la questione questa cioè fin
quando noi non esistiamo in modo
consapevole
non siamo consapevoli che c'è della
materia uno degli esperimenti ha dato
tanto tanto da pensare è stato il famoso
esperimento di entanglement quantistico
cos'è lenta come una specie di
comunicazione avviene che si prendono
due particelle ok per celle accoppiate e
poi si separano in modo l'istante molto
distante significa che io c'è una
particella ad esempio che un sistema e
che per me è isolato se io vado con
determinati artifici a interagire con
questa particella cambiare per esempio
lo spin di questa particella gli
elettroni dallo spin o meno un mezzo e
un mezzo se io vado a cambiare delle
proprietà fisiche quantistiche di questa
particella istantaneamente quindi oltre
la velocità della luce perché
istantaneamente all'altra particelle
gambe spiega la terra due lune ok io
prendo una luna allarmando via la mando
via ma che se la lascio poi non ritorna
dalla terra sono divise ormai io alla
luna le dico ora invece di girare in
senso orario ti faccio gerenza il senso
orario istantaneamente l'altra l'una
dall'altra parte per visualizzare questo
qua il concesse ma com'è possibile come
è possibile questo il problema il fatto
che c'è i pulcini c'è quell'esperimento
c'è ma com'è possibile che un pezzo di
plastica capisca questo ma c'è ma che è
un po il principio dei gemelli cioè 6
quando si dice gemelli siti dai
pizzicotto lassifica l'altro ragazzi non
mi potete
è per questo che faccio il creativo
scusate ci sono esperimenti che ci
dicono che due cose che dovrebbero
essere divise in realtà non lo so mai
mai e noi ci accontentiamo intanto di
questa nozione ma in che modo questa
cosa che noi adesso conosciamo a livello
di particelle poi si applica tra un
pulcino è un robot che in zona cenisio
dovrebbe essere collegata emiliano la
descrizione delle caratteristiche di una
particella non deve essere solo affidata
all'equazione di scelte che ma lui
aggiunge un potenziale sharing e
trasparenze di londra dice capisci tutto
il mondo e chiediamo scusa alla comunità
scientifica
anche io chiedo scusa la comunità
aggiunge mio padre lei sa tutto ma noi
dobbiamo violentare messaggio
scientifico al fine di renderlo
comprensibile per il per il mondo allora
diciamo che per il principio
d'indeterminazione di heisenberg in più
io cerco di vedere nel piccolo e quindi
di capire la posizione di una particella
tanto più questa particella scapperà via
velocemente come se avesse tanta energia
perché tanta energia uguale a tanta
massa c'è un limite perché sennò la
particella in prove su se stesse in un
buco nero quantistico
è ok e c'è un limite una lunghezza campo
di planco lunghezza di planck la
lunghezza di planck è una lunghezza
piccolissima è uguale a dieci alla meno
32 centimetri alla sata una regola una
regola per portarci avanti non puoi né
utilizzare più per diviso in meno
poi non può utilizzare il quadrato e
radice non può utilizzare uguali
capitolo cani dopo i panni di avere una
pallina da golf
siamo sulla pallina da golf e questa
la espandiamo fino al grande quanto
l'universo che conosciamo diventa
gigantesca ebbene se io li vado a vedere
in questo nuovo spazio espanso la
dimensione della pallina io l'augurio
lunghezze piangono la vedo ancora cioè
un milionesimo ancora del diametro della
pallina ecco questa è una lotta quella
di lunghezza della lunghezza di planck
perché qual è
qual è la lunghezza di plastica come
ricordo
per farmi capire quante piccola questa
lunghezza è quella che si può superare
si è quella che non puoi certo esplode
tutto è non l'ho capito per cosa dove e
in che modo in che modo non si superato
guardando
siamo in un sistema dove lo spazio tempo
a che fare con la gravità quantistica è
quindi siamo in dimensioni molto molto
piccole queste dimensioni sono così
piccoli che arriva da un certo punto non
si può passare sotto questa dimensione
ok non si può diventare più piccoli
piccoli piccoli a questo non cesate hai
detto la parola giusta
mi spaventa che a dire quanto arriva
anche lo spazio e quantizzato cioè lo
spazio il vuoto non è continuo e
quantizzate accenni il vuoto in realtà
c'è ci sono e quanti si quanti di vuoto
ok quindi il vuoto non è continuo ci
sono delle equazioni che descrivono
questa l'equazione di wheeler de witt le
soluzioni di questa equazione sono the
loop infatti si chiama gravità
quantistica a loop sono dei cerchi the
loop l'intersezione di questi loop
creano dei nodi e questi nuovi sono i
nodi di spazio
o è semplicissimo e
aspettare che ti facessimo
stiamo parlando di teorie di frontiera
cioè dove la fisica sta ancora lavorando
ok sono teorie non sono leggi sono
teorie che però sono fino adesso stanno
dando dei risultati no ok sono due le
teorie di frontiera la teoria delle
stringhe la gravità quantistica a loop
ce ne spieghi queste due teorie di
frontiera come se fossimo dei c l'intera
ti quella delle stringhe necessita di
spazi multidimensionali 11 dimensioni ma
in poche parole ti dicono che qualunque
cosa no e così vita da queste stringhe
che vibrano avaria frequenza la
vibrazione di queste frequenze creano la
materia dai i protoni neutroni le stelle
l'universo e cosa sono infatti queste
stringhe supponete siamo dei
piccolissimi tipo di smagliature
filamenti invece ammirare piccoli o
grandissimi e anche the loop dei cerchi
che vibrano ok
siano cose che erano cose va bene la
materia
mi sto vergognando le diverse parti
stavano di lo bello chiaro chiaro io mi
ricordo che il mio professore di fisica
al liceo mi guardava sempre con aria
spaventato gli diceva bravi lei mi
spaventa perché sta sempre in silenzio
vuol dire o ha capito tutto non ha
capito niente e credo di avere la
risposta chiedo scusa prima di fare
questa domanda quando si pensa al
multiverso mondo spiderman e attendibile
come viviamo design ragazzo se qua sono
mosse di fantasia eccetera c'è da però
il multiverso è una una teoria ben
concreta dimostrata matri ma anche
matematicamente e via di questo passo
quando si è creato il big bang il big
bang lo scoppio è un'espansione
un'espansione che è avvenuta più
velocemente della luce perché lo spazio
si muove più veloce della luce e diciamo
molti sostengono che non si è che si è
creato solo un universo si sono creati
infiniti tantissimo diverse all'inizio
avevamo detto che tutte quelle
particelle che un tempo per unite e poi
si dividono comunque rimangono in unità
quindi noi eravamo prima tutti quanti
criniti uniti quando il big ma quando
ancora alterazione dello sco si chiama
singolarità tutto è racchiuso in un
punto quindi una densità di energia
gigantesca quindi si è creato qualcosa
da qualcosa non sappiamo da cosa ci sono
delle teorie ma non ne parliamo qua per
favore perché se no e quindi david bowie
ha teorizzato questo fatto questa azione
spettrale possiamo correggere cos'è un
azione spettrale nazionale tu non vedi
questo tipo di atti sono ok io la chiamo
azione chiamata azione spettrale e
parole che a voi interessano significa
che c'è un universo esplicito che quello
che noi esplichiamo questo quel tratto
ma tutto quello che noi vediamo deriva
danno un universo implicato che non
vediamo che non vediamo quindi tutto
quello che avviene nel nostro mondo
reale giusto viene creato oltrepassando
questa lunghezza che la lunghezza di
planck il panel anche l'ho lasciato pure
all epoca una cosa che non viene creato
in un mondo implicito facciamo un
esempio banalissimo facciamo capire
perché tutto è collegato tutto è uno e
uno e tutto anche vero che la nuova
fisica è molto vicina alle dottrine
orientali bonu fa questo esempio
banalissimo c'è un acquario ok c'è un
pesce rosso ai due monitor una
telecamera messa in un la da un lato
dell'acquario e l'altra telecamera
ortogonale nell'altro parte dall'altra
parte dell'acquario una davanti uno dei
lato e
ortogonale ora davanti a una dell'atto
tube di due pesci per te esistono due
sono separati ma poi guardi guardi marti
e vedi che quando si gira uno altro si
mette di lato e vedi che c'è
un'interazione ma che è una
un'interazione spettrale no è la stessa
cosa questi capisce solo stesso pesce e
sapete visto però da due da due
angolazioni diverse noi siamo in questa
situazione
cioè noi vediamo delle cose che ci
sembrano separate perché è un mese un
costrutto della fee della religione e
della filosofia occidentale viene dai
greci che tutto è separato ma nella
filosofia orientale questa cosa non è
vero l'uno è tutto e tutto è l'uno
facciamo un'altra senso e fa del boom
prendiamo un foglio di carta lo
ripieghiamo tante volte e poi facciamo
un taglietto quando lo stand diamo noi
vediamo tanti buchi riguardi guardi
guardi e hanno tutti quanti alla stessa
lo stesso profilo e inizia a sospettare
qualcosa ma questi sono collegati allora
e non solo stesso ecco cosa sostiene
bombe che in questo universo implicato
in effetti in tutte unito ed ecco lenta
glam questo fatto che a distanza
infinite giocando la proprietà di una
particella e l'altra particelle
istantaneamente cambia proprietà perché
perché in effetti non sono mai state
separate le vediamo nella nostra nella
nostra dimensione nostra dimensione è
morto molto strana è se io mi dicesse a
che velocità vista del momento poi
adesso veloci siamo sicuri non è vero vi
state muovendo alla velocità della luce
perché nello spazio siete fermi ma nello
spazio tempo tutti noi stiamo viaggiando
alla velocità della luce fuori c'è tutto
lo spazio per noi questo esperimento
mentale
lo capiamo che fuori c'è tutto lo spazio
ma non è vero perché fuori c'è lo spazio
tempo noi siamo spazio tempo sono due
cose che scrivo le stanno insieme quando
io ti dico
fuori c'è tutto lo spazio e non fuori
c'è tutto lo spazio tempo ma fuori
allora c'è tutto il tempo e quindi sì
che significa che fuori c'è tutto tutto
ciò che accadrà a te a me a lui e tutto
ciò che è accaduto non esiste nel
passato nel presente esiste ora se tu mi
dici che nello spazio tempo e contenuto
passato presente e futuro 28 si si non
c'è libero arbitrio a questo quadro la
vita è favolosa perché questo
cazzate
ci baciamo sul liberalismo perché se noi
andiamo su questi concetti di frontiera
libera video non esiste quindi è destino
puro noi anche il destino è stanco è
così e basta un suo parente arrivare un
sistema se tu hai tutta l'informazione
sul sistema posizione velocità ai c'è il
futuro del sistema però la cosa inizia a
farci un po male quando il sistema siamo
noi ma l'uomo al cuore la mente è sempre
il sistema quindi questo libero arbitrio
libera vita è una cosa un po anche un po
religiosa non questo dio che ci lascia
liberi e tu sei in grado di decidere
eccetera eccetera ma se io so che tu sai
che io so io non sono più libero se tu
allora però descrivi il corpo umano
l'uomo come un sistema freddo
cinicamente visto no allora cosa serve
un lavoro migliorativo di coaching lo
fai la stessa identica domanda cioè
perché lo nodo bravo se noi siamo così
schiavi figli e soggiogati da quella che
è diciamo un binario a cosa serve
effettivamente allora è quello che io
incarico valori mentendo come coach
necessaria un'elevata fare queste
domande
diciamo ben posta anche perché le cose
importanti sono le domande non le
risposte come dice il coach perché devo
fare un miglioramento di me stesso ok
cosa che è già prevista ma tu non lo sai
il coccio normalmente cosa fa poi
diciamo delle domande domande che devono
essere pertinenti ben precise e che non
devono influenzare ok le risposte del
coaching cioè del del cliente il
nocciolo di tutto è che il coach ha già
tutte le qualità per raggiungere i suoi
obiettivi non ne ha pulsa pevolezza e
questo e fa il coach non è uno psicologo
una volta questo genere o no lascia in
modo più libero il coach i di esprimersi
la risposta quindi è comunque
all'interno di quel percorso che dice
michele era già scritto che tu avresti
e riprogrammato è è risposto davanti a
quello che ti è successo a b e c della
vita cioè al fine di fare questo perché
esiste tutto lo spazio bene in tutto
questo i pulcini sono diventati i polli
quindi possiamo un attimo torna in
quella gabbia perché la partita
prendiamo questo fatto della gravità
quantistica
adesso mettiamo in connessione con
quello che viene chiamata coscienza a
parte sulla coscienza ci sono tante cose
da dire perché la nostra morte è proprio
questa noi non abbiamo paura della morte
fisica non certo noi abbiamo paura di un
io che non riconosce più 6 il se il se
stesso abbiamo paura di perdere non la
nostra coscienza il nostro cervello a
100 milion i neuroni 100 miliardi di
neuroni arte
miliardi dai ma a mille per cento
miliardi di sinapsi significa che in
questo kg di tofu perché un po
diverso lo sforzo quando io vado a
vedere in sezione microscopica non vedo
neuroni aido sinapsi collegamenti poi
ogni tanto il timone a seta sono tanti
pallini ma legati tra di loro da molti
più fili che li da morte profili che va
benissimo però nella corteccia sono
presenti 20 miliardi di neuroni nel
nostro cervelletto piccolino sono 80
miliardi passi di più se di più e vi
dirò di più molta gente a 40 anni si è
accorta che non aver cervelletto
abbiamo quindi una differenza non
strutturale tra quello che è la
corteccia che ci sono tutti questi
collegamenti e il cervelletto che invece
è più compatto le cellule cervelletto
sono come se fossero delle cellule
singole come se fossero dei pixel di un
sensore di fotocamera roger ben rose
hameroff si muove articolo è dicono
semplicemente questo che nelle sinapsi
vi sono degli dei microscopici
esoscheletri e dei piccoli tubuli
chiamati microtubuli dentro i
microtubuli abbiamo le cosiddette
tubulina questo tubo linea 21 si
sovrappongo i 40 millisecondi siamo uno
stato di coscienza la funzione d'onda
che descrive questi microscopi e a un
certo punto collassa in 25mila i secondi
e da lì sia il quanto di coscienza
chiaro chiaro
quindi la fase di pre coscienza quando e
chi lo sa cioè quando io muovo un
braccio in realtà io questo pensiero che
faccio mi viene da qualcosa che va oltre
quello che il mio pensiero di braccio il
nostro cervello c'è un qualcosa che si
attiva prima ancora che noi le sa
pensiamo di voler fare una cosa sta nell
quindi io voglio prendere questo
bicchiere ma in realtà io non l'ho
voluto prendere perché invece c'è una
roba che si attiva a livello quantico
prim'ancora che secondo livello quanto
c'è qualcosa che mi ha fatto attivare a
prendere questo qui è quando abbiano
questo collasso sia proprio un ente
clement di tipo quantistico su tutto il
cervello cioè cervello si comporta come
un computer quantistico è come se
avessimo all'interno del nostro cervello
delle antennine che sono collegate un
collegamento confronti di quello che è
lo spazio no dico di tool per cui quando
tutti grati il mento in realtà prima
ancora di aver iniziato a fare c'è stato
un qualcosa che sia attivata prima
ancora che tu te ne rendessi conto sono
anche prima di pensarlo prima che nasce
il pensiero e se fossi al collasso della
funzione d'onda si è unita di tutte le
queste tubo linee nasce il pensiero
quindi questo pensiero e indotto
arrivato a questo punto ma è a sé ma se
avevi pensato c'era il sesso si
svegliasse cosa diceva ora lo faccio
notare è rotta
se poi ci pensa te un attimino quello
che sono i nostri pensieri non sono i
nostri pensieri tutte le vostre
invenzioni e ci dice in realtà vengono
dal di fuori ci siamo ci verso michele
michele il tuo approccio per esempio
alla scrittura la creatività ed a una
domanda seria a volte hai questa
sensazione che arrivi un po dall'alto o
no non è che arriva dall'alto parte dal
fuori quell'evidente c'è parlo di cose
che succedono fuori da me e parlo di
come io le vedo da dentro ma quando ti
arrivano quelle intuizioni di parole
musica
l'elemento da cui capisci se una canzone
può essere efficace o meno e che tu non
pensi più che l'hai scritta tu che un po
si sposa anche così suona parole che noi
siamo come degli enormi walkie talkie
blanco ecco infatti tutte le grandi
intuizioni e che con la parola perché
questa pre fase e proprio l'intuizione è
proprio quello che collega la legge di
attrazione e in questa intuizione che la
legislazione funziona nella tua
intuizione non nei tuoi pensieri
l'intuizione quella che cambia veramente
il mondo quella che diciamo è arrivata a
che i grandi uomini da loro stessi detto
è venuta da da da fuori viene da una
coscienza distribuita da una coscienza
che il tutto è che in collegamento con
il nostro 1 con la nostra coscienza
quindi questa qui è un qualcosa che va a
spiegare in maniera più tra virgolette
concreta scientifica perché poi c'è
questa connessione tra quei pulcini e
quei robot esattamente com'è che allora
a questo punto noi possiamo
effettivamente in un certo senso quali
sono i consigli al fine di predisporsi
all'essere diciamo un'antenna la prima
cosa un problema di atteggiamento capire
che tutto quello che accade e per
stabilito l'essere umano vuole essere
lui il primo attore della propria vita
questo è l'errore e non
deresponsabilizzare però così perché
quando tu sai che tutta l'informazione
l'universo è contenuta intenti viene una
grande pace capisci che tu non sei solo
che tutto quello che accade alla fine ok
è per il tuo bene nel senso che anche le
cose cattive le cose brutte accadono
come differenza tra il tuo io e il tuo
se superiore ok ma in realtà dal tuo
discorso quello che io vado a pensare a
noi in realtà siamo evidentemente a
servizio di qualcos'altro sempre ecco
già il primo passo ma avete detto già il
primo passo quindi depotenziare lio
perché noi viviamo in una società che
esalta lio e come si fa a depotenziare
lino cioè la leggenda e san paolo cade
da cavallo e urta la fa a terra il
cavallo e il nostro orgoglio quindi per
depotenziare lio dobbiamo ridurre il
nostro orgoglio iniziare a portare poi
sensi dall'esterno verso l'interno ed è
una cosa difficile è ma proprio questo
cioè portandoli verso dentro se stessi
non si potenziali in realtà no no perché
tu vai a cercare quella connessione col
tutto che è importante per te perché
quando tu inizi a portare i sensi verso
l'interno significa il tuo io ho già
capito che ti sta facendo male inizia a
prendere consapevolezza della situazione
tu diciamo sposti i tuoi sensi
interiormente non è che sposti i tuoi
interessi verso l'inter e si no ecco
ecco è una cosa e questo bravo hai detto
bene interessi non più passioni la
passione fai tu parte del sistema se tu
hai una passione per qualcosa ok
impieghi tanto della tua vita tanto data
in quella in quella sola situazione non
ti fai coinvolgere ne soffre per cose
anche stupide ma se tu invece la vedi in
terza persona quella passione diventa
interesse sei tu l'osservatore e quindi
puoi studiare meglio quello di cui tu
hai passione essere a sua volta
distaccato questo è una cosa
fondamentale per la vita bisogna essere
gli steccati delle passioni sì perché le
passione ti uccidono perché una volta
che tu se in una passione se inscatolato
in quello la tua libertà non te ne rendi
conto
ma inizia a essere modificata quando noi
diciamo chi siamo fa diciamo nome
cognome professione
quali sono le tue passioni e con sole
due passioni ma tu non sei questo
svegliati con sé in nome il tuo nome tra
l'altro te lo danno i tuoi genitori
neanche ti caratterizza il tuo cognome
quindi la tua diciamo storia storia
alcun onere la tua dignità vedete tutto
unico 16 ciò che hai in mente dio è lo è
ciò che hai tu non sei ciò che fai e tu
non sei ciò che gli altri penso di te
cioè la tua reputazione il tuo cognome
la tua storia quindi la prima cosa in
più ma se questo sennò è inutile che
fate altro questa cosa molte persone
imparano sbattendo la faccia duramente
su determinate cose di me la imparo nel
senso poi metterlo in atto è un altro
paio di mani non è facile però ne sei
consapevole già quando più di una cosa
se ne sei consapevole
cambia tutto le cose accadono nel mondo
affinché clio inizi a togliersi e
iniziare a venire fuori se superiore
quindi quando succedono dei guai per
siamo questo qualche successo non cos'è
il guaio è una differenza da come tu
vorresti che le cose andassero e da come
effettivamente vanno ammazzo io non ce
la faccio più adesso siamo quasi alla
fine ragazzi avete delle domande ultime
domande essendo una persona piuttosto
pratica quando dici che dovresti
guardarsi dentro c'è io vorrei proprio
sapere i processi che devo fare per
inizio per esempio a praticare la
meditazione inizia a contare fino a
dieci prima di fare una cosa o di dire
una cosa perché tieni sempre la
consapevolezza accesa essere sempre
presente a te stesso perché la mia vita
è qui e ora non tra un attimo o l'attimo
passato pensiamo che questo mondo
secondo questa filosofia occidentale
bacata sia un mondo di causa effetto se
io prendo un raffreddore per esempio
mercoledì il mondo occidentale tutti
diciamo certo martedì se è uscito hai
fatto lo smargiasso che è ora ti sei
ammalato e preso il raffreddore ma è
anche vero che tu prendi il raffreddore
mercoledì perché giovedì non dovevi
essere in un posto la freccia del tempo
e reversibile il tempo in effetti non
esiste alla fin fine perché a livello
quanti come a livello microscopico non
esiste non esistono le nelle equazioni
scompare il tempo il tempo è solo una
posizione ha capito perché anche nelle
cose cattive che avvengono perché
perfino e ragioniamo sempre come causa
effetto scendono casa porca miseria
dimenticato le chiavi e c'era la luce
accesa del bagno piccolo inconveniente
ma quello avviene no perché tu sei stato
sciocco perché ha dimenticato le chiavi
per che stanno scenata è stato shock
alimentano le chiavi e ha dimenticato
nei cani perché perché dovevo salire
spegne la luce al bagno io ultima
domanda all'interno di questo
ragionamento di voi tutti quanti siamo
collegati collegati ma di base esseri
all'interno di un ingranaggio più grande
di noi e tutto quanto dove anche la vita
stessa è relativa con un importanza
perché la sofferenza un'altra persona
potrebbe realtà a portare me a tirar
fuori un qualcosa di utile ma non per me
in generale per hicks che sempre diciamo
un terzo come si posiziona la scienza
all'interno del concetto proprio di
morte alla scienza per adesso non si
posiziona questo senso di morte ci sono
molti per esempio casi di pre morte ok
andy si chiamano near death experience
queste esperienze di pre morte significa
che la persona ormai è incosciente siamo
in sala di rianimazione non mente sono
99 passaggi no l'estrazione dal corpo di
questa coscienza le persone si vedono in
un angolo della stanza e beto cosa sta
facendo i medici come stanno operando
eccetera eccetera è come se questa
coscienza arriva ad un certo punto stack
questo corpo e guarda fuori poi parlano
tutti di un tunnel di una luce c'è un
benessere meraviglioso tant'è vero che
molte persone sono arrabbiate di
ritornare di nuovo quindi se noi siamo
effettivamente dei walkie talkie che
vengono attivati da qualcosa che siccome
se io spegnesse il walkie talkie ma di
base che parlata dal sole walkie talkie
continua esiste diciamo che per esempio
quanto rimane skin e turi sente alla
radio ma nella radio non ci sono rimane
schiena ma tu è l'esperienza di mano e
skin ai delle visioni dei money skin ma
innanzi non sono della rai maneschi non
sono la radio più in solo alla radio
paio dire che ci siamo ce l'abbiamo
fatta noi chiediamo sempre se c'è
un'ultima cosa che che vuoi dire adesso
sinceramente no puoi anche dire basta
non ce la faccio
e chiaro che qui siamo a livello di
scienza di confine la cosa che e
importante è capire quando una coscienza
e dentro individuo questo kg di tofu
come fa esserci un incosciente dentro e
questo che la scienza sta vagliando
bisogna stare molto attenti con la
coscienza perché coscienza vuol dire
proprio il passaggio perde la coscienza
significa morire cioè non c'è più quel
io no chi è cosciente di sé c'è tanta
paura perché noi viviamo così nel loro
nel senso perché quel per l'uomo ciò che
è importante è il senso delle cose e
quindi io lavoro faccio costruisco
eccetera e poi cosa per poi essere
annientato qual è il senso ecco perché
l'essere umano non vuole allontana
questo allontana vero che che precipita
perché per l'essere umano il senso delle
cose è il senso del senso ha importanza
sono con sostanziali
chiudiamo così chiudiamo siamo su
quell'aereo che sta precipitando con una
coca cola in mano cosa dovremmo fare
qual è l'ultimo consiglio di avere fede
quindi vi è la via la coca cola e guarda
fuori dal finestrino la fede è una
fiducia in qualcosa di assurdo non in
qualcosa che è dimostrabile direi di
finire con la canzone dell'isola che non
c'è che chi non crede forse più pazzo di
te ma l'isola non c'e anzi mi leva è
stata bellissima di sognare grazie
grazie ma com'è andata sta cosa s
allora ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine
di questa puntata io vi chiedo scusa
perché è veramente stava fumando una
certa secondo me ce lo vogliamo chiudere
al volo michele puoi farci to l'unica
dei quanti che mi stanno impedendo le
grandi nella vicina a lei a non ho
capito tutto le cose che ho capito mi
hanno buttato in una dirigenza
stato speranza invece pensate miky ma tu
tra tutti sei depresso beh questo tipo
no perché comunque una cosa molto
complessa cioè avere una visione così
ampia e poi rifletti che dio 27 anni
della mia vita allora a questo punto li
ho fatti nella cecità mi sento un
fallito ma
veramente non chiuderemo maicon questo
tuo commento chiudi direttamente perché
tanto in questo decido io anche questa
puntata di feroci volge al termine e
speriamo vi sia piaciuta e se tutto
questo è stata stata negata abbia fatto
tutta una chiacchiera pazzesca mi puoi
fare la tua voce quella di rotta
emotiva per favore della g che voleva
essere un po più felice sul finale e
portiamo la così anche questa puntata di
feroci volge al termine speriamo mi sia
piaciuta e se tutto quello che ci siamo
detti oggi è vero magari è proprio così
che cazzo di frasi questa cosa vuol dire
se è tutto vero e proprio così e c'è
verso di te questa cortesia
speriamo che vi sia piaciuta ma se tutto
quello che abbiamo che abbiamo detto
oggi è vero quindi che i nostri desideri
hanno un potere sugli altri
evidentemente così perché noi abbiamo
capito non molto chiara affanculo non
smettete di concedervi la possibilità di
immaginare di sognare di creare mondi
popolati dalle migliori versioni di
quest esse per soprattutto non perdete
la voglia di indossarle ricercare di
calzarle perché così come ogni grande
gesto è nato dal seme di un'idea così
ogni grande persona è stata prima un
bambino direi a questo punto che siamo
pronti ad affrontare la puntata che
segna la meta perfetta di questo podcast
una puntata che ha come protagonista un
tema di film a posso riprendere un
cammino il tema difficile che ci vuole
concedere anche l'occasione di parlare
di felicità di amore e di vita da noi
feroci è tutto ragazzi e ragazze a non
avevo tolto gli occhiali un graffio
[Musica]
[Applauso]